non madame Denis Saint-Pée pour le
groupe Union centriste pour 4 minutes
[Applaudissements]
mais si le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues le texte que nous
allons examiner aujourd'hui revêt une
importance toute particulière alors que
nous connaissons une crise énergétique
sans précédent à l'heure où le spectre
d'une pénurie d'énergie ressurgique
d'autant plus menaçant que notre parc
nucléaire est pour moitié indisponible
il est en effet plus nécessaire que
jamais d'accélérer notre production
d'énergie renouvelable cela permettrait
d'éviter à nos ménages nos entreprises
et nos collectivités locales de subir
délestage rationnement ou blackout tout
en garantissant notre souveraineté
énergétique et en s'inscrivant dans la
lutte contre le changement climatique il
ne s'agit pas pour autant de négliger le
nucléaire dont nous nous sommes tous
bien conscients des atouts cependant la
production de nouveaux réacteurs
s'inscrit dans le long terme là où les
énergies renouvelables peuvent répondre
à nos besoins énergétiques dès
maintenant le gouvernement semble avoir
pris la mesure de l'urgence avec ce
projet de loi qui contient de nombreuses
mesures de simplification et
d'accélération des procédures et je m'en
réjouis mais ce texte reste perfectible
et c'est pourquoi je tiens à saluer le
travail accompli au Sénat par les
différentes commissions impliquées il
montre l'attention de notre hotte
assemblée à ce que la transition
énergétique menée par l'État ne se fasse
pas contre les collectivités
territoriales mais bien avec elle ma
collègue d'avenir ragmadou détaillera le
point de vue de notre groupe sur les
avancées proposées par la Commission des
affaires économiques notamment grâce à
l'engagement de notre collègue
rapporteur Patrick Chauvet
pour ma part j'accueille favorablement
plusieurs propositions de mon collègue
rapporteur Didier mandeli fait en
commission aménagement du territoire et
développement durable je pense par
exemple à la définition à la limitation
de la phase d'examen de la demande
d'autorisation environnementale à 4 mois
ou encore au référent préfectoral à
l'instruction des projets d'énergies
renouvelables et des projets industriels
nécessaires à la transition énergétique
par ailleurs ces amendements visant à
démultiplier les possibilités
d'implantation du photovoltaïque me
semble indispensable pour maximiser le
déploiement de cette énergie cependant
je déplore que certains amendements
votaient en commission mettent en péril
l'édifice que nous avons co-construit
comment pouvons-nous ainsi proposer de
revenir sur le dispositif équilibré de
la loi 3DS sur l'éolien un envisageant
aujourd'hui un veto des élus municipaux
sur les projets d'abord cela ralentirait
la procédure ce qui serait
contre-productif
plus dangereux encore cela mettrait les
projets éoliens terrestres à la merci de
critères politiques et donc subjective
un risque d'autant plus accru si toutes
les communes en covisibilité sont
concernés aussi je ne crois pas
raisonnable ni responsable d'instaurer
un tel dispositif de même comment
soutenir des mesures visant à gêner
l'implantation d'éoliennes offshore à
moins de 40 km des côtes quand dans le
même temps l'éolien flottant qui permet
d'aller au-delà de cette distance n'est
pas encore mature c'est à se demander si
nous avons tous la même conscience de la
gravité du moment en pleine crise
climatique et énergétique mon groupe
n’étant pas uneanime sur ces questions
la vie que j'ai exprime représente celui
d'une partie de mes collègues nous
comptons tous néanmoins sur le débat et
des jours à venir pour que le
gouvernement et le Sénat s'accordent sur
des solutions de compromis
satisfaisantes je vous remercie
pour
4 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues notre collègue de
Nice Saint-Pée s'est en prononcé sur les
articles relevant de la Commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable mon intervention
ne portera que sur ce délégué au fond à
la commission des affaires économiques
je ne peux commencer quand on félicitant
notre collègue rapporteur Patrick
Chauvet pour l'excellence de son travail
et pour l'attention particulière qu'il a
eu à essayer de trouver des solutions de
synthèse quel que soit la technicité des
sujets abordés
les apports de notre commission des
affaires économiques sont nombreuses
insertion du stockage de l'électricité
dans le dispositif de la loi
facilitation de la production du biogaz
encouragement à la production
d'hydrogène vert ou possibilité de
renforcer les capacités des
installations hydroélectriques mais le
temps qui m'est imparti ne permettant
pas de tout traiter je me concentrerai
donc sur trois points le premier sans
doute le plus préoccupant pour les
territoires et bien sûr l'objectif de 0
artificialisation nette le fameux âne
qui inquiète avec la transition
énergétique les territoires se trouvent
confrontés à un conflit d'impératif
d'écologique d'un côté il faut limiter
l'artificialisation pour préserver les
milieux naturels de l'autre il faut
construire et développer des
infrastructures énergétiques pour
décarboner notre mix
il est donc nécessaire d'articuler les
deux pour que l'artificialisation
énergétique ne phagocyte pas tout le
potentiel au détriment de l'aménagement
local et en l'état actuel du décret de
la nomenclature d'usage il fallait
impérativement en sortir les
infrastructures énergétiques
très exactement ce qu'a fait notre
commission sous la houlette de son
rapporteur
se faisant elle a ouvert la boîte de
Pandore c'est le premier aménagement à
l'objectif zan depuis son adoption dans
la loi climat et résilience madame la
ministre il n'y en aura d'autres votre
gouvernement s'est déclaré favorable
nous les accompagnerons attentivement
avec pour ligne directrice de rendre
l'objectif zan applicable sur tous les
territoires sans le vider de sa
substance
le deuxième point que je souhaitais
aborder le partage de la valeur un
élément clé en matière d'acceptabilité
des projets de NR or le dispositif
initial en fléchant l'intéressement sur
les riverains donnaient l'impression de
vouloir acheter le silence on pouvait de
plus craindre que ce partage ne soit
dans les fêtes anecdotiques nous avons
adopté en commission une réorientation
qui augmente le montant du partage
puisque ce dernier était tendu à toutes
les EnR et que le versement forfaitaire
sera complété par une contribution
territoriale servante à financer des
projets locaux de transition écologique
de plus notre commission l'a rendu
collectif et public ce qui semble plus
sain et logique le dernier point que
j'aborderai en conclusion est plus
problématique il s'agit de la
déclinaison territoriale des objectifs
de production d'énergie décarbonée
comment satisfaire nos besoins nationaux
avec des projets non pas seulement
acceptés mais même voulu par les
territoires
concernant les éoliennes terrestres la
problématique et caricaturale et
clivante mais elle se présente en
réalité pour toutes les énergies bas
carbone des centrales jusqu'au patoon
photovoltaïques en passant par la
production biogaz
nous devons trouver un système de
gouvernance de la transition énergétique
qui conserve toujours cet équilibre
entre objectif de production et soutien
territoriale or ce dispositif nous ne
sommes loin de la voir notre commission
a néanmoins commencée à poser les jalons
en permettant aux collectivités qui le
souhaitent d'améliorer leur
planification énergétique via le schéma
de cohérence territoriale le Scott et de
manière simplifiée demain la
programmation plurianielle de l'énergie
devrait nous apporter un cadre global
c'est du moins un tel cadre que nous
appelons de nos vœux et madame la
ministre nous serons à vos côtés pour
l'élaborer
merci chers collègues